was like a plum long kala
hey everyone and welcome to our guide to
need for speed payback brought to you by
EA I'm Dan Marr and today we are going
to be tackling a subject that's very
close to my co-hosts heart isn't that
right Annie
it's all about the car customization
it's what my company does we wrap cars
and this game is allowing us to wrap
cars and customize it to how we want
good stuff what I'm expecting great
things let's get into it
so now we're a dealership it seems that
this show and definitely specializes in
off-road the land drivers so we've sort
of got the Brawn
we've been driving a lot of fast car
yeah yeah let's go with a tank cause
50,000 we've got 56,000 our bank we're
broke am i right Island racing Jess back
to the airfield we are taking a route
that she can't take in here that will
run a car I think I've got it yeah yes
like that Jess oh now he's at speed cars
what does that mean what do you want 1 2
or 3 middle middle jump send it's cotton
rat in the guarantee I okay we're the
garage demise let's go baby
okay so we've got got vanity items paint
and wrap stance tuning visual
customization and performer so it's it's
strongly suggesting that we do a bit
performance customization you earn that
new speed card head gonna go boost in
horsepower liner got a big boost in air
time a big increase in landing when we
go to look at the wraps it available
exactly that where I wanted to go read
your mind I say well let's give you the
reins cuz this is this is clearly your
your area of expertise my vast array of
colors you want some oh if you're
dealing in the nighttime races summit
that's gonna make you a stand out in the
dark let's go let's go plum drugs we've
got logos we've got letters camo camo
this for a bit camo in there mate I'm
all about a bit camo so yeah you can
start sure
can start rotating it let's make it a
bit smaller than yeah that's just filled
up on it though since the roof yeah
photo roof on as well for they out same
same dica yeah we are very Safari now if
there's any elephants out there watch
out yeah I love her games though have
really developed and they added the rap
element to it because rap is only being
around sure whirling yeah yeah what you
saw lot a number of options available
what people are gonna be drawing stuff
you're gonna be seeing some crazy stuff
getting out there but there's there's so
much else we can be doing we can we
change the camber front rear camber we
can be changing them ride high they put
down the flow of the car we go with it
here we go mate look low that's what I'm
talking about keep going drop it to the
floor nice so we can change physical
parts as well so that's the official
Land Rover side skirt and then we've got
a few few customs for the site these
boys yeah the other ones nice holes
everywhere a mere 200 from our vast
13,000 fortune there we go you can
change everything that our break this
the calipers the rims that can all be
changed so I like it we've got all these
conditions purely to be able to change
all these aspects of the car license
plate we can be changing or do on well
what's that names together just make em
done yeah and on its official
partnership is a fist on the speak to
dvalin and I buy that today all right I
think that's enough customization I
think to get this back out on the road
we need we need people to witness this
beauty in action there so there you have
it that's your taster of the
customization options available to you
in Need for Speed payback it's really
extensive and right off the bat you can
change your paint jobs and you can
change your decals as we've demonstrated
with what we called the Y and and plum
camo van that's our lovely Land Rover
Defender if you can raise enough money I
love the fact that you can change the
gearbox ECU engine exhaust and obviously
my favorite the car wrapping so I think
it's about time we had a bit of a
faceoff we know there are some epic
jumps around
Need for Speed paybacks huge open world
so I think it's time we found some of
those and had a bit of a jump off what
do you think we're no longer friends
lying to me see an exponent
[Applause]